plus everything oh we are P1 Harmony and
we're with BuzzFeed to take a witch P1
Harmony member are you quiz let's get
started let's go
first question let's go first how would
your BFF describe these scary funny
sweet chill smart confident maybe spawns
you
I love it I think my BFF's gonna
describe me a chill yeah chill I would
say chill well would you guys say me
scary
what there's not enough which hair color
suits your bias most my bias who's my
bias myself you have to pick myself
yeah my bias is myself okay then
everyone just pick yourself dark blue
you've never done Darkness
that's the hair I did for scared
orange yeah you're always orange pink
you have to make a viral Tick Tock what
type of content are you creating singing
v-logs freestyle bands I wouldn't
I like it though I would do a dance gym
I feel like dancing they're like the
easiest to get bottles oh I'm gonna pick
death train are you dancing as well you
said I wouldn't you said I wouldn't I
wouldn't what would you do committee
yeah okay choose an activity for your
ideal day off
I can pick photography and skateboarding
shopping video games can't be more
fetching for me something I mean I
always go shopping I like to spend money
when your days are off those are the
only times you can really spend money
and I like to you know treat myself
every now and then yeah I'll choose
shopping I already know all of your
guys's answers so video games
but these days I want to go camping too
in Korea there's this thing called
glamping which is like camping but like
you don't have to do all the hard work
so we can just go there and everything
set up for you already yeah
I feel like that's really good and it's
pretty cheap too let's go then now
choose a song to play on repeat
Butterfly by Umi this is my favorite
song I Love This Is It butterfly
butterfly okay wait a little bit of an
acoustic moment right now
take me down at home yeah I really like
Bruno major
I'm gonna also see butterfly that's like
a classic right now I think that's the
song that I always go back to pick
something tasty to eat
well I will eat anything like that okay
they have really good Korean food in L.A
though right really a lot of the time
like delivery is like not the best
because it always comes like cold and
stuff like that but Korean food is
always great if you could be another P1
remember for a day who would you choose
one question I'm gonna say why you
choose me because you're good at dancing
I want to be able to move like that a
little bit I'm gonna come out randomly
how much shoes
oh that's good
I'm gonna pick you or so because that
too is very good at chords oh fourth
capability and sports ability they have
good coordination and they like just
pick up Sports and physical activities
very easily compared to the rest of us
in terms of is like the worst no offense
oh
[Music]
this is pretty accurate he got himself
you got Kyo others find you easy to talk
to and shuko
[Music]
you have the ability to be sweet and
sexy at the same time
that's the point that's right
who wrote this
yeah I mean so soon I got myself it's
like 80 accurate I wish I got myself
that I'm a little upset thank you for
watching this Buzzfeed video we had so
much fun figuring out which member we
are in P1 Harmony is very fun and very
accurate also our new song Back Down is
out please look forward to it please
listen to it please stream it please do
whatever listens to the album we worked
really hard so we hope you guys like it
thank you so much this has been P1
Harmony thank you
[Music]
foreign